宜しくお願いします
ヒューマンビートボックスという言葉を聞いたことはありますでしょうか
ヒューマンビートボックスというのですね口だけで様々な音を出して一つの音楽を表現
する
そういった
文化ですでまずハッシュさせたんですけども
どんなものか試してみたいと思うんですが口だけで今からドラムの音を出してみたいと
思います
いきます
th
b
ん
[音楽]
がとうございます
その他にもですね
様々な交換を出すこともあります例えば
ブーン
rrd
うん
[音楽]
2分
[拍手]
ご覧いただいた通り僕の仕事は口だけでいろんな音を出す仕事をしています
まず最初ですね少しだけ僕はこのヒューマンビートボックスに出会った時の話と
始めた理由を話させて頂きたいと思います
高校生のときに
皆さん経験があるかお金のわからないんですけども
死ぬということに対しての
ことに僕は以上雨での恐怖を感じたことがありました
実際にどういうことかというともう朝も
触れるぐらい
フライが止まらないぐらいの時だったりとかあとは
実際に外に出ることにできなかったり学校に行くこともですねちょっとためらった時期
もあります
幸い学校はの夏休み期間中方の大丈夫たんですけれども
a
そうですねあのこの c ということに出して深く考える時期がありました
この死ぬということに出してぼくはこのままじゃいけないと思い真剣に向かう時期がき
ました
そして2つのことに気づいたんです1つは
まず
せませんちょっとスライドを申しますね一つは
必ずしもしというものは全人類平等に訪れるものなので
意外とあっさり受け入れられたなということがまず一つありました
でももう一つの方がですね何のために生まれて自分が生きた証をどう残すか
そうです名器な c ということに対して非常に恐怖を感じただということに気づき
ました
それから僕はあるひとつの人生の目標を決めたんです
それは歴史に名前を残すということでした
あの少々大げさかもしれませんが
その目標を掲げたときに今まで嘘のように
不安や恐怖が一切なくなったんです
で次にどうやって歴史に名前を残すのかということに考え始めたんですが
例えばタレントになって有名になる
または映画監督になって素晴らしい作品を残す
政治家になって国を変える
どれもすばらしいアイディアだったんですけれどもちょっと漫画の読みすぎかなと
まああまり実感が湧かないというか実現がたのだとあまり
思えなかったんですそんなある日たまたま地元のデパートでプロのヒューマンビート
ボクサーのパフォーマンスを見る機会がありました
もちろんテレビや cm ので見たことがあったので情報はいくつかありましたが生で
見るということがその日初めてだったんです
そして会場に開く足を運び彼が登壇しパフォーマンスを始めました
こういう感じです
いい
ん t ん t ん
ブーブーブーブードゥ
日
アドゥリン
[音楽]
[拍手]
当時の僕は
かなりこれがそういう知的でした
口から何個も同時にをとかなって
テレビや動画じゃ絶対に感じられのような重点をや迫力
それを生で感じて僕は一瞬でこのヒューマンビートボックスの虜になりました
当時この出会った時が二十歳だったんですけれども音楽を始めるにはちょっと遅い
スタートというか
さらにはですね音感もなければ歌も特別上手いわけでもなくて
音楽の知識もあったわけじゃなくて曲に合わせて手拍子することすらもままならない
リズム感でした
なので僕は
人よりも一生懸命練習しなきゃいけないと思い毎日毎日練習しました
時にはお風呂場で練習しすぎて母親から怒られたこともあります
今日はそんな母を見に来ていただいています
ある分
th
で一生懸命練習してきうちにイベントに呼ばれるようになり気付けば毎月10本以上の
ライブをこなすまでになっていました
でも僕の目標はですねライブでパフォーマンスすることが目標だったわけじゃないん
です
歴史に名前を残すという目標がありましたなので次のステップは世界だと思い
世界に進出頃することを決めましたそれがこちらの写真なんですけれども
実はこれは2009年に開催されたワールドビートボックスチャンピオンシップという
ドイツベルリンの大会なんですが
世界60ヶ国以上が集まって一対一で向き合い a 大会を行うのですが僕は残念
ながら
大会の出場権がなかったためショーケースとしてゲストパフォーマーとしてください
万惣するだけでした
でその後ですね他にもロンドンに行ってパフォーマンスをしたり
ニューヨークのアポロシアターに出演したり
ロンドンロシアやシンガポールの部分日本大使館に呼ばれて
世界場とか訪問することができるようなりました
でも一つだけ
感じてことがあります何かというと日本と世界をつなぐコミュニティは期間がなかった
んです
ヨーロッパだと陸続きなのでもう国境を越えた
コミュニティがどんどんどんどん出来上がっていて日本だけ取り残されている感覚で
期間を非常に感じましたなので僕は帰国してすぐに
一般社団法人日本ヒューマンビートボックス協会刀流を設立しました
当時僕は23歳だったんですけれども
何も経営もわからないまま手探りで作業しそしてまず最初に何をやろうと思っているか
と言うと
japan ビートボックスチャンピオンシップという日本一を決める
公式の大会を開くことにしました
もうご覧の通り会場には沢山のお客さんが来ていて今では参加者が600人以上いて
へ
全国で大会を行っていますこのたいかどんなものかというと先ほど言った舞台に世界と
よマジで
一対一で向き合って制限時間があり抗体抗体にパフォーマンスをして
クリエイティビティやオリジナリティミュージカリティーと様々な項目を審査員が
ジャッジしてそして勝敗を希望
優勝を決める
日本一を決めるという大会でした
一種のスポーツの大会のようなコンテンツだと僕は思っています
で自分で主催しながらですねなんと出場し優勝しましたね
ありません
あの
ちゃんとですね国がいたらあの
審査員を呼んで公平な社長からとでずらしてません
をしている
また優勝しました
で4年連続で僕は優勝して今はあの大会のプレイヤーとしては外れたんですけれども
こういうことを活動してやってみましたそして日本一になって世界で活動するように
なり
テレビや cm に出演することが多くなりました
そして
プロのヒューマンビートボクサーとして生計を立てれるようになったんです
やったぞこれでまずはファーストステップクリアをして実家に帰り
父親に報告しました
すると家中がこう言いました
すごいなぁ
それでお前はいつ就職済んだ
開いた口がふさがらなかった多いまで覚えています
あの国で初めて気付いたのはヒューマンビートボックスという文化が社会に認められて
いないんだっていうのに気づいたんです
もし仮ですよ
これがキュリギアスケートだったり野球サッカーだったらおそらく父親の言葉を代わっ
ていたと思います
そしてそのことに気づいて毎日毎日どうやったら
1 box が社会に認められるんだろうというふうに考えるようになりある日
またこの日本一決定戦を開催した日に1人の男性に声をかけられたんです
そしてその彼はこういうふうに言いました
た生産
素晴らしい大会を開催していただいて本当にありがとうございます
実は僕はパニック障害という障害を持っていて
遠征から9日以上に来るまですごく困難なことが多かったです
ですがどうしてもビートボックスの大会に参加したいという気持ちで
家族の方に引率していただき去年は
来れるようになりましたそして今年
[音楽]
もう一度見たいそういう強い強い気持ちがあり
今年は1人で来ることができました
これから
自分らしい人生を送れそうです
そう言って僕の手を握り感謝の言葉を伝えてくれました
デカかったですね
今まで自分が自分のためにビートボックスをやってたんですが初めて人の為に何か
できるんだということを気付かされた瞬間でした
この
もしヒューマンビートボックスを通して
自分のためではなく人のためにそれが社会のためになるんだとしたら
ヒューマンビートボックスという文化自体が社会に認められるんじゃないか
そういうきっかけになるんじゃないのかなと思うようになり
様々な活動をすることに決めました
目が見えない方も
車椅子の方も
声がでない方もヒューマンビートボックスを通すと一緒に一つの空間で音楽を共有
できるそういう素晴らしいものだと気づけたんです
実際に現在はですね
あの
[音楽]
視覚障害の
子供や知的障害の子どもが通う養護学校でビートボックスを教えに行ったりとか
健常者と障害者が一緒の空間で1 box を楽しんで学び人前でパフォーマンスする
というプロジェクトをスタートしたりとかそういう社会のために人のために何かでき
ないかということを活動しています
ですねあの
僕の仕事はこうやって口を出し口から音を出して人に何かを与えるという職業なんです
けども
もともと英語が喋れなかった僕がこうやってですね
国境や言語した生涯一バ一目つとしてありとあらゆる境界線を取り除ける
そういう文化だと初めてここで気づくことになりました
これからですね
先ほど紹介した日本一決定戦のような大会がですね
スポーツとして認められるようになったらオリンピック競技を目指したいなと思ってい
ます
でもこのオリンピック競技っていうのは
健常者のためのものだと思うんですけれどもパラリンピックとオリンピックの垣根を
越えたコンテンツはビートボックスにできるじゃないのかなっていうふうに僕は今思っ
ているんですけどおそらくそんなカルチャーは今までになかったのかなと
なのでぜひ生で1 box の大会を youtube でもいろいろ今流れてるん
ですけれども皆さんに知ってい
いただきたいなと思いますえ
本日はありがとうございました
そしてですねー
最後なんですけれどもせっかくこの場を頂いたので母親に怒られながら練習したビート
ボックスを披露したいと思います
ウェディ人チャンミンじゃあの民車んをっ
呪紋ヴェーバーショーケースはぁっ
うん
ん
うんうん
[音楽]
ブーイング
聞いた
[音楽]
re done
ん
[笑い]
[音楽]
いいいい
seem
[音楽]
ウォッは
voodoo
[音楽]
いいいい
あるございましたん
[拍手]